so as you saw there Cheltenham Keene Lib
Dem target seat I'm now joined by the
party's deputy leader said Davey thank
you for being the studio and with us
today and I'm keen to get your response
to what I found in Cheltenham but first
it feels we should really start with the
terror attacks and the tragic scenes
that we saw on Friday at London Bridge
what how should politicians be
responding to that what happened well
first of all we should be thinking of
the victims and their families this is a
huge strategy and we're incredibly
grateful to the emergency service and
the public he was under so amazingly
I've been a bit alarmed though about the
way the Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
responded he seems to be politicizing
this at a time when we really should be
thinking about the families and worse
still he's misleading people about what
the current law is he's trying to say
that there is early release now but
actually that was got rid of in 2012 and
Liberal Democrat Justice Minister Tom
Anneli put forward legislation which has
meant that the earlier release no longer
happens you now you a terrorist offender
has to serve at least two-thirds of the
term and then it's not automatic release
so what the Prime Minister is calling
for has already happened some people
would say you say that early release
doesn't happen anymore some people would
say that if you don't serve the full
sentence that you were given that is
early release and that's what Boris
Johnson is trying to stop
well the parole board would make the
decision the new legislation and afraid
the Prime Minister was misleading people
again on television you last night he
said that people the look the current
law is that people get early release
after 50% the term that's not true and
either he's incompetent and doesn't know
the law or he's deliberately misleading
people when we've got a tragedy on our
hands and I'm afraid either way does not
look good for the prime minister and he
should be apologizing and you know we
shouldn't be making in the middle
election political cattle out of a
tragedy and he's doing that and he's
doing that in a way which is misleading
people about what the law actually says
we'll be putting some of this to Dominic
Rob later on the program the and
foreign secretary i'm jeremy corbyn in
the interview that I did with him
earlier said that he doesn't think it
should necessarily be the case that
terrorists should serve their full
sentences what's the Liberal Democrat
position we stand by the Lord that we
strengthened where terrorists should
should serve at least two-thirds and
then what the decision shouldn't be
taken by politicians it should be taken
by the parole board under the old law
that was passed before it was
automatically released the parole board
wasn't involved and he only came off he
percent the term the new law which libel
Democrats helped get through because
they have to serve two thirds and then
it's not automatic then it's based on
the evidence and if they are still
dangerous they are kept inside as they
should be I think that's the right
balance and that's the truth unlike what
the prime minister saying I'm afraid he
has a track record on misleading people
on this issue on brexit on on so many
things
I'm really alarmed that we are on the
brink of having a prime minister who is
the most untruthful prime minister of
all time okay that's a big claim and I
will be putting to Dominic Robb later on
and I'm sure of course that the
Conservative Party would dispute that
look is record we've never had a prime
minister who's been sacked from two jobs
for lying sack from the front back from
the Conservative Party sacked from a job
as a journalist he he hasn't made a
career out of misleading people and I'm
afraid on many issues including Brett
said he's misleading the British people
I'm keen to talk about brexit and about
the Liberal Democrats position in the
election as well and we've just seen a
film from Cheltenham I have to be honest
I went there thinking it was going to be
an absolute shoo-in for the Liberal
Democrats it's a seat that you've held
historically it's a seat that voted to
remain it's a seat where the
Conservative Party do not have a big
majority but it was a lot closer then I
thought it was going to be when I went
out on the streets and talked to people
about how they're feeling I mean are you
a bit worried about the way the
campaign's going we've seen great
response in target seats like Cheltenham
and many seats that vote a strongly
remain where it's the Liberal Democrats
attacking the Conservatives and their
MPs it does really seem to me that if
we're going to stop Boris Johnson
getting majority it's going to be the
Liberal Democrats who can do that in
seats like Cheltenham so if people want
to prevent
Boris Johnson with his very right-wing
agenda his his brexit agenda they want
to prevent that happening in seat after
seat a vote for the Liberal Democrats is
the way to do that the same time though
and I can't help but feel that for many
voters the reason that they don't really
like the idea of Boris Johnson as Prime
Minister or Jeremy Corbyn as Prime
Minister is because they did they're
quite extreme politicians and yet by
adopting a position of revoking article
50 if you're in government are you not
just making yourselves an extreme party
no what we've said is we want to stop
brexit that's the policy and we want to
do it democratically and the most likely
way is that we'll be having a people's
vote mm ik rats have led the campaign
for a people's votes so it's up to the
people to have the final say we put a
mint 72 amendments down the last
Parliament and led those in with the
labour who it does it does feel sorry
contexts that land is bad I can't be now
fixed in gang I can't accept that we
have said all along that we are the
people's vote party we have added the
fact that if we won a majority and there
was a political earthquake which when
made meant that we went from 12 MPs two
years ago to 326
yes we would see that as a democratic
mandate and I think that's fairly
indisputable but failing that saying
that political earthquake the Liberal
Democrat position and had always been is
for a people's vote because we do want
to take the people with us we do want to
end the divisions in our country which
the Conservatives have caused and we do
want to help people getting given the
chance to stop practicing and some of
the recent polling and seat projections
has shown that perhaps the big
expectations at the beginning of the
campaign are let's say not quite being
met I mean there are lots of polls we'll
just have a look at one in particular
this is a you go poll on the 29th of
November
putting the Conservatives at 43% Labour
at 34 the Liberal Democrats on 13% now
of course it's one poll but it is
reflective of what we're seeing across
the board which is the Lib Dems having a
bit disappointing campaign on you well
it is only one poll but I'd also say
that the election in Britain today is
fought in seat by seat
so there will be parts of the country
where we're not doing very well but the
other parts where we're doing incredibly
well and in our target seats
particularly seats where there's quite a
big remain vote and seats where we've
got great local candidates we're seeing
a much better rating than you've just
shown and we believe we can take a lot
of seats offices and some of labour and
others but it's the seats we take off
the Conservatives which will decide this
election this election could be decided
by Liberal Democrat victories if a
Liberal Democrats win in seat after seat
against the Conservatives we can stop
boys Johnson and people are seeing
jeremy corbyn's party going backwards
it's really clear from poll after poll
that Corbin is going to lose seats so
he's not going to be the prime minister
but we can start a bond Boris Johnson
majority if people backers in those key
target seats the polling also showed you
slightly brutally that the more people
see a Joe Swinton your leader unless
they like it but not in our target seeds
in our target seats he's incredibly
popular you go in and actually poll
remain voters she's really I'll be
honest a lot of people brought her up in
a negative way when I spoke to them I
just have to speak and Sophie that's
that's fine but in poll after poll that
we've seen in target sees Joe is
incredibly popular and let's look at a
seat a poll that's been out just just
this weekend and it shows in Easter and
Walton which has been a traditional
conservative seat the Liberal Democrats
are on the verge of beating Dominic
rather Foreign Secretary a key brexit
here as a remainder just come behind us
and you know what's gonna be critical
and I'll be frank with you in the next
few days is if the third party vote if
it's a Labour third party for example
when we're fighting the circus if that
comes to the Liberal Democrats in places
like issue Morton but in many other
places too we can stop Boris Johnson and
we're the only party who can stop Bruce
Johnson now you of course ran against
Jason Winston for the leadership of your
party what would you have done
differently
nothing I think she's been doing a
fantastic job
I think her leadership on the brexit has
been in
aspiring and I think the fact that she's
put investment education and childcare
at the top of agenda and climate change
one of the reasons why campaign one
reason why we want to stop brexit
because you forget the individuals one
reason why Jo is so right that we want
to stop brexit is because then you get a
remained bonus and you'll be able to
have much more money to invest in
education then you'd be at the table on
climate change talks
I think pulling out of Europe when
climate the climate immersion is so
important I think it's a climate crime
if you really care about climate change
you should be at every international
table arguing the issue the climate
emergency is probably the biggest
challenge facing this country and the
world and we've got a wise up we
represent 1.5 percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions just 1.5
percent so we could be brilliant but the
rest of the world could fry so if you're
not of the EU table if you're not at the
United Nations table you are frankly
giving up on climate change and that's
why Liberal Democrats want to stop
brakes if we want to be at the European
Union table so we can persuade others to
take the actions that are necessary to
keep our planet safe okay just finally
is there a chance that Joe Swenson might
be Prime Minister who knows I'm not
going to judge the British people before
they voted it's not looking as likely as
I'd hoped it would be but you know the
polls have not even opened yet Sophie
okay
Davey thank you very much for coming in
the studio today much appreciated